[Music]
so amid everything else that's going
down like crypto and stocks and
everything there's something really
interesting happening
and this is being recorded in new york
new york in uh 2007 there was up to 432
public sex citations wow that had
happened like around the world central
park yeah look at those nuts
yeah 433 these homeless people or were
they like
no they were highly sexy people
oh homeless people can be sexy excuse
you they are people do they not have
it's unhoused
in new york is that what we call it in
california they're called the unhoused
oh they call it homeless people give a
[ __ ] yeah
i don't have a house dude i could lord
it used to be called transient homeless
people are just like um excuse me yeah
it's unhoused [ __ ] latinx
so where my mom lives there's a bunch of
homeless people that are like starting
to like kick it in there
literally next door literally next door
um and these [ __ ] people have a
microwave bro how to get electricity
that's what i'm saying any like bumps
music he has like this big ass speaker
that lights up and [ __ ] and i'm like
that's why it's unhoused it's different
from homeless that's his home still a
little bit it sounds like you're jealous
of that sound system yeah that's what it
really is that's the reason he doesn't
invite me to the party
so there's so this is a giant rise in
public sex uh so
this is a 2019 record pre-pandemic guess
how many
citations there were for public sector
six thousand
wow six thousand two thousand two
thousand okay one more modest you've
said 400 before right 432 in 2007 which
was it kind of like a high oh 2007. oh
wow over 10 000. ten dollars okay in
2019
there were zero citations that's what i
said because of covet basically well
they're having sex inside now
no that's the thing is they don't know
why there's such a massive drop in
public sex of all things
they're just not signing them up [ __ ]
zero know what yeah they're just not
getting caught yeah there's no citations
there's no jobs yeah this is what ryan's
like and miraculously there were zero
officers who checked for this [ __ ]
because they were the ones [ __ ]
bigger fisher fraud well that's the
thing could that be the reason is
that the officers are just now not
giving a [ __ ] i think they're just
shooing them away
hey get out of here you just get hoses
yeah get out of here i'm [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] over here
what are you doing people from new york
hate that [ __ ]
get out of it shut the [ __ ] up
they're probably
that's a
all
gopro
new york talks like little italy i was
in little italy they're like oh you got
a gopro in your hand huh
i went to new orleans with uh with a
buddy for a batch party we got in the
taxi or uber and my buddy's uh is it new
orleans down at new orleans he's like no
it's new orleans
just killed his spirit instantly
it's a knowledge you know what the
dramatic drop might be i heard that like
gen z's ain't [ __ ] no more yeah
that's probably true question what's
happening with your people what do you
mean that's not my people i'm a
millennial bee that we discovered right
the [ __ ] is that because
the millennial group is so big that
there's a a and a b
which one's the worst one because i
don't want to be the beast
yeah we're all [ __ ] bro millennium b is
all millennial [ __ ] falcons does
anybody have any personal reasons why
they no longer participate in public sex
but who here has had public sex me
what are the stipulations of public sex
so like yeah the public is seeing you
that there is a there's a chance that
you could get caught a car in an
untinted window okay car sex counts then
it sounds easy yeah
hello everyone raise your hand is there
a reason why you don't do it as much now
yeah because we have a home where we can
cause [ __ ] road rage he gets angry at
the car
my car
my car gives me so much frustration when
i drive you know why because tim can't
get in the car before he leaves
he's like baby just do that [ __ ]
like the accelerator's under the seat so
his ass weight just makes it go
she's just grabbing the spoil of the
cars
baby wait for me
i don't need you i'm using david's
technique where i just imagine
[Laughter]
it works i wouldn't want to get caught
in a public park like in in new york
though because it's like
it's like i don't wanna i don't want
like a bomb to see me [ __ ] and be
like can i join
that's what you're concerned about i
don't think you care i think you're just
making a [ __ ] no i'm shy
i want to be in a place where a hot girl
would be like can i join where's the
craziest place you guys have had sex at
david's front yard yeah that was kind of
nice though if it's front yard when we
were having sex it's great
it was me it was
yeah so what about you guys
uh i guess a balcony where the the it
was all glass so they could see
everything it's fun oh yeah really
really tall balconies where you feel
like everybody can't see but you know no
one can do [ __ ] makes you feel all
powerful it's kind of tight so what's
yours
uh disneyland parking structure mickey
mouse level
good lord
i know i know that scene that's
dangerous
that's what made it so dangerous not
disneyland wait wait was it was it upon
arrival or before departure it was
midway it was midway it was midway
he's a season yeah he's a season walked
out did it went back in so when she was
riding you and she had the mickey ears
and you had the mickey mouse mickey ears
too did you did you [ __ ] she had
mickey ears and i had mickey mouse
two male mouse
you both had mickey ears
i bet you want this goofy dick
[Laughter]
it's super risky yeah because
everywhere well just cause there's kids
but we did but we did take like you know
like random sweaters or jackets and
stuff like that and put them all like
roll down the window they'll put them in
there roll them back yeah that's not
obvious yeah did you turn on the ac yeah
did you do the handprint thing like in
titanic
yeah
they took turns doing that yeah okay me
me me
i've always wanted to
what is the big mickey hand
just four fingers
there's no sound either just soft
it's super silent
it just wipes the mist so it's super
clear out there people can see it's
like oh [ __ ]
that mickey club is awesome
the uh the craziest thing i did was when
i think was like 15 or 16 16 16. i had
sex in one of those uh
photo booth things at like
the mall yeah
but they could see your legs still yeah
but just looks like you're taking a
photo that's true a very rigorous photo
that's a crazy photo you got it dude
that's going to come out blurry
some [ __ ] lady but the reason the
reason why i
uh completely like stopped doing that is
because i heard
that
you can potentially uh get a sex offense
that's the same reason why i don't i
don't like piss in public i heard you
get from peanuts yeah you get it from
that too
if they want to be like 10.
don't stop people you pick your parents
on the road [ __ ] yes
yo
she was crazy
[Laughter]
what do you
[Laughter]
like wait why are you peeing in a public
[ __ ] the [ __ ] yeah
yeah see oh wait whoa
he [ __ ] [ __ ] in front of a kid
he just
twisted that he can't see she's just
going
but how do you do it okay excuse me
no it was actually really cute it was
really cute tell them why you're peanut
butter well you tell them because you
how are you cute because i everything
[ __ ] disneyland is cute you [ __ ] so i
forgot who was peeing first
but we were on an rv road trip right and
then
and then i think she got out to pee
and then i think taika was like oh me
too
so tiger's a sex offender too yeah see
they're both pink and i said lock him up
i took a picture and then i actually got
it made i have a big ass blown up
picture of mom come over i'll show you
guys isn't there a toilet in the rv
there is i knew that
yeah i know i was like somebody asked
someone please ask but as i'm like you
guys are not going to ask okay so there
was right but it's one of those that you
like you put on the hitch so
everything's locked up it's not like one
of those that's attached to it right
that's why there's a hitch you
see my plans
i didn't know but i didn't know bart was
gonna get that offended before then yeah
he flipped out i kind of got nervous
because you think i'm gross and i'm like
you just as girls dude no i'm not i'm
it's a human thing okay everyone peace
is the can well i disagree let's just
all pee right now let's be on the phone
right now and just to get on with
see i wonder if you look up like the sex
offender thing there's already a red dot
for bart
wait wait that's a kid i know
the best thing is
at a stop and this fool scrubbed his
[ __ ] so hard in public at a shower in
front of a bride so she they were in
front of a bride they were doing
engagement photos in maui and you can
see her she has this beautiful dress
okay okay she's like washing her feet
because in the sand like this and you
see bart just
just
gonna be clean
at a certain point the [ __ ] water
starts turning red that's how
i've never seen somebody scrub their ass
so hard your ass just bleeding she was
sanding his butt
was clean though my ass was clean yeah
it was exfoliated too that fool was
polishing it i wish you guys could have
seen the lady's face she was mortified
she really was this fool was ripping in
there you know what she should do she
should mind her own [ __ ] business
her dress was red
[Laughter]
she's a matter of [ __ ] business stop
eavesdropping on people's showering
techniques right you didn't that wasn't
like you wouldn't get in trouble for
something like that right no i mean like
you share the beach right like a like
you have a they're getting [ __ ] he's
washing his ass
photos yeah i'm a local so i'm over
there i should be allowed to watch my
[ __ ] in public
i'm [ __ ] taking my nice shower and
then one by one just like a rainboy come
out you see [ __ ]
dudes of honor whatever the [ __ ] they're
called dudes of honor what are they
called holy
dudes of honor and groom's mates y'all
on fire
now you are slowly becoming your father
as you continue to
he's the groom's maid the father
i don't [ __ ] know now they all
started coming out and i was just
cleaning my ass i was like i was here
first if you guys want to watch that's
on you man hey you know what that's what
i believe that i have some real [ __ ]
that's what makes me realize i think the
number one reason why people stop doing
this [ __ ] is because it's so easy to be
recorded now oh
yeah compared to 2007 yeah coming in
with the logic bro damn that went over
our heads i heard people in central park
be [ __ ] all the time yeah they used
to yeah check it out see that's the way
but it's a big park do you think the
cops are just patrolling and like
looking at everybody whistling with a
baton
tiny cops
yeah the big [ __ ] clown shoes yeah
the [ __ ] constable
and they're doing this hey quit [ __ ]
here
[Music]
[Music]
you